the name of the game with Affiliates is
activation my opinion poor people
up Affiliates is they're like here's a
bunch of good luck if you think of
them as customers that it's way easier
because then it's like what's my
onboarding process you don't have to get
them to pay to become an affiliate you
have to do all the work for them I will
say that each level of Leverage you add
adds a whole another level of complexity
because you have yet another customer to
serve I would recommend just going one
level up learning that one and then once
you have that dialed then go another
level up because each time you get more
libraries and then you can prove out the
success that you're going to bring that
person's customers and then it makes the
conversation either rather than like I'm
figuring all this out at once and
I'm going to figure out how to work with
you and all your customers and all their
customers like it's really tough
appreciate it thanks